salts can form acidic solutions neutral
solutions or
basic solutions when dissolved in water
for example if we dissolve sodium
chloride
in water solid sodium chloride turns
into sodium cations
and chloride anions in solution at 25
degrees celsius
the aqueous solution of sodium chloride
is neutral
and has a ph of 7. the reason why the ph
is equal to 7
is because neither the cation nor the
anion reacts with water and water
has a ph of 7 at 25 degrees celsius
and since neither the cation nor the
anion react with water
the ph remains 7. in a different
solution it's possible for the cation
or the anion to react with water and
turn the solution either acidic
or basic therefore to predict if a salt
solution is going to be acidic
neutral or basic we have to analyze
whether or not the cation and the anion
will react with water and there are four
possible combinations of cation and
anion
the first combination is neither the
cation
nor the anion will react with water
and if that's the case the resulting
solution will be neutral
we've already talked about an aqueous
solution of sodium chloride
being a neutral solution the way to
approach this is to look at the chemical
formula
and say sodium chloride consists of a
sodium
cation and a chloride anion
the next step is to analyze the cation
and the anion and think about if they
react with water or not
to determine whether or not a cation
will react with water it's helpful to
think about a list of common strong
bases
that consist of group 1 a metal
hydroxides
and the heavier group 2a metal
hydroxides
if the cation is from group 1a or the
heavier group 2a
the cation will not react with water for
example in our case we have the sodium
cation and since the sodium cation is in
group 1a
the sodium cation will not react with
water next we think about the anion
to determine whether or not the anion
will react with water it's helpful to
think about a list of common strong
acids if the anion is the conjugate base
to one of the strong acids
the anion will not react with water
for example in our case we have the
chloride anion
which is the conjugate base 2 hcl
since cl minus is the conjugate base to
hcl cl minus
will not react with water a good way to
think about this
is to think about hydrochloric acid
being a strong acid
and the stronger the acid the weaker the
conjugate base
therefore the chloride anion is such a
weak base
it will not react with water so we say
the chloride anion is of negligible
basicity
and since neither the cation nor the
anion react with water
an aqueous solution of sodium chloride
will be neutral
as another example let's think about
barium nitrate
barium nitrate consists of the barium
two plus cation
and the nitrate anion because the barium
two plus cation
is from the heavier group two a the
barium two plus cation will not react
with water
and because the nitrate anion
is the conjugate base to a strong acid
which is nitric acid the nitrate anion
will not react with water
since neither the cation nor the anion
will react with water an aqueous
solution of barium nitrate
will be neutral the second possible
combination of cation and anion
is where the cation does not react with
water but the anion does
when this combination occurs the
resulting solution
will be basic an example of this second
combination would be
barium acetate so barium acetate
consists of the barium
two plus cation and the acetate
anion since barium 2 plus is on our list
for heavier group 2a barium 2 plus will
not react with water
however the acetate anion is the
conjugate base to acetic acid
and acetic acid is a weak acid and is
not on our list
of strong acids since acetic acid is a
weak acid its conjugate base
is strong enough to react with water so
the acetate anion is a strong enough
base to react with water
and when acetate anion reacts with water
it forms
acetic acid and hydroxide ions since the
concentration of hydroxide ions in
solution have increased
that's what makes the solution basic
this is called anion
hydrolysis when an anion reacts with
water
to increase the concentration of
hydroxide ions in solution
as another example let's think about
sodium hypochlorite
which consists of the sodium cation and
the hypochlorite anion since the sodium
cation is from
group 1a the sodium cation will not
react with water
the hypochlorite anion is the conjugate
base to hypochlorous acid
since hypochlorous acid is not on our
list of common strong acids
it must be a weak acid and if it's a
weak acid its conjugate base the
hypochlorite anion is a strong enough
base to react with water
therefore increasing the concentration
of hydroxide ions
in solution so since we have a cation
that does not react with water
and an anion that does react with water
an aqueous solution of sodium
hypochlorite will be basic
the third possible combination of cation
and anion
is where the cation will react with
water but the anion will not
in this case the resulting solution will
be acidic as an example of this third
combination let's consider an aqueous
solution of ammonium nitrate
looking at the chemical formula for
ammonium nitrate it consists of the
ammonium
cation nh4 plus and the nitrate anion
no3 minus first let's talk about the
anion
the nitrate anion is the conjugate base
to
nitric acid which is hno3 since nitric
acid is a strong acid its conjugate base
is of negligible basicity so the nitrate
anion does not affect the ph of the
solution
it does not react with water when
thinking about the cation nh4 plus
nh4 plus is the conjugate acid to nh3
which is ammonia and since nh3 or
ammonia
is a weak base its conjugate acid nh4
plus
is strong enough to react with water and
when the ammonium cation nh4 plus reacts
with water
it forms the hydronium ion h3o plus and
ammonia
so the nh4 plus is increasing the
concentration of hydronium ion
in solution which is what's making the
solution
this aqueous solution of ammonium
nitrate acidic
as another example let's consider
aluminum chloride an aqueous solution of
aluminum chloride
looking at the chemical formula aluminum
chloride consists of the aluminum
three plus cation and the chloride anion
the chloride anion is the conjugate base
to hydrochloric acid which is a strong
acid therefore the chloride anion does
not react with water
the aluminum three plus cation is not
from
group 1a or a heavier group 2a
therefore we can conclude that this is
going to react with water
so small cations with charges of two
plus
or greater can react with water
let's look in more detail how the
aluminum three plus cation can function
as an
acid in aqueous solution the aluminum
three plus
cation interacts with water molecules to
form a hydrated metal ion
water is a polar molecule and
the positively charged aluminum three
plus cation
interacts with the negative end of the
water molecule so there's an
electrostatic attraction between the
negative end of the water molecule
and the three plus charge on the
aluminum cation i only drew in one
water molecule however keep in mind
there's actually six
water molecules interacting with one al3
plus cation
in the hydrated metal ion the strong
electrostatic attraction withdraws
electron density from
this oxygen hydrogen bond which makes
this proton
easier to remove therefore when another
water molecule comes along so right here
in the equation
this other water molecule can take this
proton leaving these electrons behind
the oxygen
and if you're adding an h plus on to h2o
you form
h3o plus losing an h plus means the
charge in the hydrated ion
went from a three plus down to only a
two plus
and increasing the concentration of
hydronium ions in solution
means the ph of the solution will
decrease
therefore a hydrated metal ion can
function
as an acid however it's the strength of
this interaction between the cation and
the water molecules that determines
if the hydrated metal ion will function
as an acid or not
for a small cation with charge of two
plus or greater
that gives a large electrostatic
attraction to the water molecule which
makes this proton easier to donate
however if the cation is too large or
the charge is too small
the electrostatic attraction is not
strong enough to make the proton
easy to donate and that's the reason why
cations from group 1a
or the heavier group 2a don't interact
strongly enough with water to
affect the ph of the solution therefore
if we have an aqueous solution of
aluminum chloride
the cation aluminum three plus will
react with water but the anion the
chloride anion will not
since the cation reacts with water the
resulting solution will be acidic
the fourth possible combination is where
a cation will react with water
and the anion will also react with water
in this case the resulting solution can
be acidic
neutral or basic as an example let's
think about an aqueous solution of
ammonium carbonate
looking at the chemical formula for
ammonium carbonate
the cation would be the ammonium cation
so that's nh4
plus and the anion would be the
carbonate anion co32
minus we've already seen that the
ammonium cation will react with water
and the carbonate anion if you add a
proton onto it that doesn't give us an
acid on our list of strong acids
therefore the carbonate anion is a
strong enough base to react with water
first let's look at the equation showing
the ammonium ion reacting with water
so this is cation hydrolysis since the
cation is reacting with water
in this case we would form the hydronium
ion and ammonia
next we think about the carbonate anion
reacting with water so this is
an ion hydrolysis when the carbonate
anion reacts with water
it forms hydroxide ions in solution and
also
hydrogen carbonate since the cation
hydrolysis
forms hydronium ions if we were to write
an equilibrium
constant for this acid-base reaction it
would be ka
and since the anion hydrolysis forms
hydroxide ions in solution
if we were to write an equilibrium
constant for this acid-base reaction
it would be kb to figure out if the
aqueous solution of ammonium carbonate
is acidic neutral
or basic we need to compare the ka value
for ammonium
to the kb value for carbonate
if the ka value is greater than the kb
value
the solution is acidic if the ka and the
kb values are approximately the same
the solution is about neutral and if ka
is less than kb
or you could say kb is greater than ka
the solution will be basic
to find the ka for the ammonium cation
we're going to use the following
equation
ka times kb is equal to kw
and this equation is true for a
conjugate acid base
pair so what this is saying is the ka
for the ammonium
cation times the kb for ammonia
is equal to kw which at 25 degrees
celsius is equal to 1.0 times 10 to the
negative 14th
textbooks often have the kb values for
common
weak bases like ammonia and the kb value
for ammonia
is 1.8 times 10 to the negative fifth so
we
solve for ka and we find that ka for the
ammonium cation is equal to 5.6
times 10 to the negative 10th to
calculate the kb
value for the carbonate anion we use the
same equation ka
times kb is equal to kw however remember
this is the ka and the kb for a
conjugate acid-base pair
so we're talking about the carbonate
anion
as the base and its conjugate acid which
would be hydrogen carbonate hco3 minus
so we plug in the ka value for hco3
minus
and solve for kb so kb
for the carbonate anion is equal to 1.8
times 10 to the negative fourth at 25
degrees
celsius and this ka value is also at
25 degrees celsius looking at the values
for ka
and kb ka is less
than kb since ka is less than kb
or i could say kb is greater than ka
this solution is basic